في هذه اللحظات الان وفي هذا الحدث من
موقع اخر قريب من السفينه التي سوف تقل
المعتمرين السودانيين هناك سفينه ايضا
صينيه وهي سفينه نفط وقفت قبل تقريبا
الخمسه واربعين دقيقه الماضيه على رصيف
ميناء جده الاسلامي والان كما نشاهد
القنصل الصيني وكذلك مدير اداره العمليات
في ميناء جده الاسلامي وكذلك الضباط وضباط
الصف في حرس الحدود وقطاعات امنيه تابعه
لوزاره الداخليه السعوديه هم في انتظار
نزول
المواطنين الصينيين الذين قدموا عبر هذه
الناقله طبعا لو نشاهد الصوره في الزاويه
الاخرى ويلتقطها المصور يقف اكثر من 60
شخص من
ممن قدموا وحملتهم هذه السفينه النفطيه
وهم جميعهم من الجنسيه الصينيه لحظه فقط
الاذن لنزولهم وبعد ذلك سوف تقلهم الحافله
المخصصه والتي وفرتها السعوديه وبعد ذلك
سوف ينتقلون مباشره الى مقر اقامتهم طبعا
اليوم نتحدث عن امر مختلف حقيقه الان واضح
جدا ان الامر داخل السودان وتحديدا في
بورسودان واضح جدا انه صعب لماذا لانه هذه
السفينه ان نفطيه قامت باجلاء هؤلاء
المواطنين الصينيين ولعل الامر هنا كان
اشد صعوبه
فمشاهدتنا لهذه السفينه النفطيه وهي تحمل
رعايه ايضا من الصين وكذلك ايضا تنقلهم
الى مدينه جده فان وضعهم الصحي سوف يتضح
بعد قليل عند نزولهم نعم هناك مركبات
الاسعاف وهناك ايضا اداره الصحيه السعوديه
جاهزه ومتاهبه وايضا هناك قطاعات صحيه
موجوده من اجل التاكد من سلامتهم نزولهم
طبعا الجميع هنا في انتظار نزول هؤلاء
المواطنين الصينيين هناك ايضا علامات
ترحيب وهناك ايضا من السفاره الصينيه التي
تقوم بوضع لافتات الترحيب من اجل هؤلاء
الصينيين وايضا نشاهد الحافلات الموجوده
هنا وايضا نشاهد في الجهه الاخرى ايضا
المركبات الصحيه ومركبات الاسعاف التي
وفرتها السعوديه بعد نزول هؤلاء الصينيون
من هذه السفينه لو نشاهد ضخامه هذه
السفينه والتي يبلغ طولها اكثر من 160
مترا نشاهد هي سفينه نفطيه كما تشاهدين
وهي سفينه نفطيه ولكنها ايضا
اضطرت الى حمل هؤلاء الصينيون عندما وقفت
الى بورت سودان عندما قامت بتفريغ النفط
هناك واضطرت الى حمل هؤلاء بعد بحسب ما
وصلنا بعد المعاناه التي كانوا يعانونها
من وجود وجودهم هناك رغم انه هناك
الامر كان واضح ان كان بعضهم داخل الخرطوم
شاهد امرا مؤلما واوضاع ماساويه فاضطروا
جميعنا التوجه الى بورسودان وبعد ذلك
اقلتهم هذه السفينه التي وصلت قبل ساعه
الا ربع او قبل 45 دقيقه الى رصيف ميناء
جده
الاسلاميه طبعا نحن في انتظار فقط
النزولهم هناك طبعا في هذه الاثناء ايضا
هناك ايضا رحله اجلام متزامنه ولكنها في
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه ويتم اجراء من
قبل القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه
تصلونها في هذه اللحظات معلومات ان القوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه تقوم بعمليه
اجلاء ووصول
اكثر من
250 شخصا او قرابه الثلاثمائه شخصا من
جنسيات مختلفه يصلون الان الى قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه وهي في الجهه الاخرى ومع هذا
الامر ومع هذا الخبر هناك تحرك ايضا
للمواطنين على
ظهر هذه السفينه الذين يقومون الان
بالتوجه الى السلم المخصصي لهم
وللنزول وبعد ذلك سوف نشاهدهم مشاهدات
هذا الصور هاني وسنبقى مع هذه الصور فقط
لنذكر باننا نتابع هذه الصور لوصول صينيين
على متن هذه الباخره النفطيه نحن في
انتظار نزولهم طبعا ولكن حدثني منذ قليل
وقلت بان وردتك بعض الاخبار مفادها وصول
رعايه اخرين في الجانب الاخر وبتحديد في
قاعده فيصل البحريه حدثنا عن جغرافيه هذا
الميناء بمعنى انه نحن هذه الصور طردنا من
ميناء جده في مقابله بالتحديد نتحدث عن
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بمعنى انه
المسافه كم كيف يبدو تنظيم هذا الميناء
والقاعده كذلك
نتحدث عن وصول كم سفينه لانه بيتنا هاني
لا نتحدث فقط عن وصول هذه السفينه الصينيه
ولكن تحدثنا فيما قبل عن وصول سفينه
فرنسيه عن وصول كذلك رعايه بريطانيين فكيف
يتم تنظيم هذه العمليه الضخمه
صحيح في ظل الصور الان التي تلتقطها
للمشاهد الاوليه لنزول
الرعايه الصين الذين وصلوا للتو الان عبر
هذه السفينه النفطيه سوف اخبركم عن عمليه
التنظيميه التي تقوم بها السعوديه في
استقبال سواء للفرقاطات الحربيه او السفن
التجاريه من دول عده او كذلك لسفلها
الخاصه والعسكريه التابعه للقوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه
طبعا هذه الصور الاولى ولكن سوف اعود اليك
بعد قليل الى الموضوع اساسي وهذا هو هذه
الصور الاولى وهذا هو اول الواصلين الان
هناك فرحه واضح جدا من ان الرايه الصين
الذين وصلوا للان هم سعيدون جدا من خلال
سلامهم الحار واشتياقهم للوصول الى بر
الامان هنا ايضا القنصل الصيني في مدينه
جده ايضا بهم وهناك ايضا المزيد من
النازلين من الرايه الصين على من هذه
السفينه قاعده اعود الى العمليه التنظيميه
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه هي قاعده عسكريه
سعوديه هناك العديد من الفرقات وعديد من
السفن السعوديه الحربيه التي هي فقط
المعنيه بالوقوف على هذا الرصيف لا تبعد
كثيرا عن ميناء جده الاسلامي منها جدا
اسلامي هو منفصل تماما عن هذه القاعده فمن
جدا الاسلامي هو اساسا هو فقط للسفن
التجاريه والسفن ايضا المدنيه سواء
التجاريه التي تحمل بضائع او كذلك التي
تقل اعداد المسافرين سواء الذين كانوا في
السابق وما زالوا قادمين ياتون من السودان
او ايضا من مصر او كذلك سفن كروز التي
كانت تصل
تقف على رصيف ايضا ميناء جدا اسلامي هنا
العمليه مختلفه لاننا نتحدث عن ميناء ليس
فقط هو ميناء
عابر وانما هو ميناء تجاري ضخم يعد من
اكبر الموانع الموجوده في العالم وايضا مع
الرؤيه التطويريه للسعوديه فان هذا
الميناء سوف يعزز من خدماته خاصه في
الخدمات اللوجستيه وكذلك في خدماته
البضائع في عمليات النقل
للدول اوروبا وكذلك عبر اسيا هذا هو امر
منفصل فعندما نتحدث عن هذه السفينه تحديدا
فنحن نتحدث عن وقوفها في ميناء جده
الاسلامي على عمليه الاتساع والمساحه
الكبرى التي تتسعها مثل هذه السفينه او
تقف في هذه السفينه نعم
ونحن نتابع هذه الصور المعبره جدا حدثتني
منذ قليل عن سيارات اسعاف تقف للتاكد من
سلامه الواصلين ما الخدمات الاخرى سواء
طبيه او غيرها التي توفرتها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
بخصوص هذه العمليات عمليه الاجلاء
طبعا دائما الذين يتم اجلاؤهم الى
السعوديه اولى المراحل التي يقومون بها او
تقوم بها الصحه السعوديه التاكد من
سلامتهم فحصهم التاكد من خلوهم من
الفيروسات هناك تقنيات بوجود كاميرات
حراريه يتم نقل هؤلاء المسافرين الى داخل
الصاله وبعد ذلك يتم كشفهم للتاكد من
خلوهم من هذه الفيروسات وايضا اعطائهم بعض
اللقاحات
الحيويه التي ايضا تعطيهم وتقيهم من هذه
الفيروسات او لا سمح الله من اي مكروبات
قد تصيبهم جراء تنقلهم من منطقه الى منطقه
اخرى اذا هي لقاحات وقائيه من اجل صحتهم
وسلامتهم هناك ايضا مركبات اسعاف ولو
نشاهدها ايضا ونطلع عليها ونرصدها عبر
شاشه العربيه هي تقف ايضا في حاله الطوارئ
بعض بعض الفترات او بعض السفن تطلب
سيارات او مركبات اسعاف من اجل ان هناك
حالات طارئه يتم نقلها او تكون على متن
السفينه فهناك ايضا مركبات اسعافيه
للطوارئ لحالات الطوارئ في حاله لا سمح
الله حدوث اي ارهاق او اي عمليات للتعب
جراء الرحله الطويله والرحله الشاقه اضافه
الى الرحله الشاقه التي شاهدوها سواء
كانوا من الخرطوم او بورت سودان او ايضا
اثناء سفرهم عبر الماء البحري لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات